every year on may 20th national rescue
dog day is observed to raise awareness
about our furry friends and shelters
during the pandemic rescue group saw a
huge increase in adoptions but things
have changed drastically as prices for
everything have increased they say pet
owners are forced to work longer hours
to make ends meet and for others it's
for some tough decisions like returning
their animals because they can't
financially care for them that has led
to some issues with re-adoption
when they feel really guilty that
they're leaving their pets alone in the
house
it's really sad for the pet because they
have to put them in
crates
and it's like them being jailed in their
own house so
then there's personality problems with
that animal if you want to re-adopt that
animal or you know
you know it's sad
if you're considering adopting or
re-adopting remember that pets are a
huge responsibility if you are a
struggling pet owner our community does
offer resources to assist with food
spaying and neutering and microchipping
we do have a link for that information
on our website at eight newsnow dot com